- Morning, guys.
Gentlemen.
NARRATOR: Rick Lagina
joins Craig Tester
and other members of
the Oak Island team
at the Money Pit site.
Now that drilling has
begun at a second location,
they are hopeful
they will soon reach
a mysterious
30-foot-wide void located
at a depth of some 170 feet
and which was identified
earlier by seismic scanning.
Much talked about, 87.5.
I pulled out H8 from last year.
A very, you know, interesting
and important hole,
and it spawned the
large diameter caisson.
And today, we're very
close with that one.
We're into open
ground that hasn't
had any real information on
it, you know, plus or minus
5 feet away from it.
We've got a really relatively
virgin target very close
to what I think
is the Money Pit.
This should be interesting.
You know, considering
what came out of H8,
this should be a real
hot zone for artifacts.
NARRATOR: Using a
specialized sonic rig,
the Choice Drilling team will
extract core samples of earth
and any objects contained within
at intervals every 10 feet.
These samples will
then be transferred
into a plastic
sleeve so that they
can be carefully examined by
hand for any important clues
or possible treasure.
Well, here we go.
What depth, Brennan?
160.
That's really gravelly,
but it's mostly limestone.
You see that tan color?
That's limestone.
And this silt, there's, you
know, organics in there.
What is that?
That's weird.
I think this is coconut fiber.
That's really interesting.
NARRATOR: At the Money Pit,
while searching the spoils
of the exploratory borehole
known as H7.5, Rick Lagina,
Craig Tester, and members
of the Oak Island team have
just made an amazing discovery.
When you look at the
historical records,
they did find, you
know, what they believed
to be coconut fiber
in the Money Pit
when they were excavating it.
So it's not beyond the
realm of possibility.
Exactly.
NARRATOR: Coconut fiber
in the Money Pit, 160
feet deep below the surface?
But if so, how did it
get there, and why?
In 1804, when the Money Pit
was excavated by the Onslow
Company, searchers
reported finding
a large amount of coconut
fiber at a depth of 60 feet.
Given that the nearest
coconut trees are located some
1,500 miles south
of Nova Scotia,
they concluded that it had been
used to make a kind of rope
that would enable depositors to
lower something of great value
down into the shaft.
Could the discovery
of coconut fiber
be an important indication
that Rick, Marty, and the team
have finally located the site
of the original Money Pit?
Cut.
Look, you can see that ax.
See that?
Yeah.
Somebody's hit these
things with an ax.
You can see the bevel of the ax.
This is interesting.
And what are we at again
from the top here, 1--
171.
NARRATOR: Ax-cut wood found
approximately 170 feet deep
underground and nearly
the same depth where
recent seismic scanning
revealed a mysterious
30-foot-wide chamber?
Could the Oak Island
team have just
discovered solid evidence of
the legendary Chappell vault?
Well, we are
going to want to bag
and tag these pieces of
wood in through here.
There's quite a bit of
limestone-rich material,
the matrix.
There's also a very
large rounded clasps.
We've never seen
anything like that.
And this minced-up stuff here?
That's really interesting.
This has all just
collected somehow in, like--
in the corner of something
or in a crevice of something,
you know?
Otherwise, this would be mixed.
You know, I wish I could make a
very firm statement whenever we
drill that, OK, we're
in this structure,
or we're in this shaft,
or we're in this wall.
But we don't know
the underground.
That has been proven to us
over and over and over again.
At this point, we have a lot
of data, the coring samples
that we've brought
up, and from that
maybe then get an
understanding of how
these wood structures align.
That's my hope.
But how we pursue it,
I don't know as of yet.
You have to have faith that
what you're doing is right.
I mean, like all the
searchers before, I mean,
it was always the next
day, the next hole,
the next 10 feet of the shaft.
If you don't believe that,
then it's time to go home.
When it gets tough, I go back
to Bobby Restall's journal.
We made two inches today,
and they were happy.
Yeah.
Yeah, we came up
dry, but we tried.
Yeah.
And we didn't quit,
and neither did they.
Nope.